boys a little debate club but first this
is buck Samson from Michigan it's buck
praise God
what up feel without Brendan buck
Sampson here great now to Baker toast is
through pop-tarts well me all that
pretty CH I'm noticing the looks a
ramble Chris doodle like he was honestly
afraid to admit it
first buddies they're gonna clown I'm
sitting in pop-tarts are toasters
watching this now like Keynesians ever
so early in the morning let's go to this
culture corner what about just pop-tarts
in general yeah or can you guys process
sugar what's that like for you guys yep
we could process sugar can't process
alcohol Wow dairy right yeah dairy to
look up dude what Koreans don't give a
[ __ ] though they'll still train the
power through I'll I've never seen you
do dairy though chin I use all the time
wow I bring in like little craft slices
and what do you do just go hard after
you eat it or what do you do where you
eat it in the open no I'm serious my car
maybe Oh what are you a little
embarrassed around other yes he's eating
it in his car do you know embarrassed
around another Korean people eat dairy I
mean if I mean dairy something happens
afterwards that's why oh damn my beer
garden I mean okay okay to Bruce gasps
that's why they can't have you be
farting ah so he's saying so its body
reacted yeah
well they're learning I thought you're
saying something mentally happens to you
or something oh no I just turns into the
[ __ ] Jekyll and Hyde from cheese well
I'm saying if I picture a tall Korean
guy eating cheese quietly in the
backseat of his car you don't think it's
the whole I think something's happening
here okay I agree I think like yeah I
don't assume he's [ __ ] dr. Jekyll mr.
Hyde over here does it make you angry
chin not makes me happy oh why aren't
you happy for Oh interesting
you like a sharp charge huh I like it
like cheddar regular you like like a
real sharp cheddar if you like a violent
Brie
that sounds good actually yeah oh yeah
like a prickly Parmesan sounds great you
like a [ __ ] cancerous camembert
canadaís I don't either sure you don't
but who [ __ ] with pop-tarts over I grew
up on both these or toaster strudels
pop-tarts flavors you know heated or
unheated come on heated there especially
the cinnamon ones are purified with the
maple sugar on top however I'm a toaster
strudel boy I grew up with toaster
strudels and I used to have such a sugar
problem the icing they used to give you
packs almost the latter over this was
the last like you know for all six of
them my fast would [ __ ] put one in
the toaster and I'd use three icings on
one well then my brother had beat me up
the next day oh I got beat up all the
time because of that really by your
brother the accountant the accountant no
computer program is you really yeah my
bad man it's all good dude but dude I
remember when toaster strudels came out
remember it had just been pop-tarts he
just stood around hungry in the kitchen
before school and then suddenly [ __ ]
toaster strudels hit America God they
were beautiful they were from France or
something croissants the croissant
filled God with fruit some how hot it
was dude one of my sisters still has a
huge [ __ ] raspberry burn on her
[ __ ] cheeks like a joker she just bit
right into that [ __ ] fresh out the
toaster dude immediately toasted her
mouth no hand interaction we talked
about that raspberry la la the raspberry
filled with raspberry lava and they took
icy freak on top and I do three of them
ohad bite into every now not make a
sandwich oh I do too
I see in the middle ah my brother beat
me up my brother had whipped my ass and
you know what I knew he's gonna beat me
up and I still did it Wow that's how
addicted to sugar I was I could see that
man they are
and they they were really just a
beautiful treat when they first hit the
scene man there was nothing like a mess
hit the blue box with the little white
guy bar writes the first box god damn it
that's America they're back that they
let you Owen the ISIS knows I would draw
like a smiley face on there right now or
draw a knife why not I know why not bro
or draw a piece of cheese on there like
chin would do and just eat that the
imaginary dairy dude that reaches you
come out with a new product imaginary
dairy Chen's lactose treat and it's just
a little lactose you use it's like
little see here's the thing too now that
I don't know how they still make them
now everyone's a girl [ __ ]
health-conscious shut the [ __ ] up
yeah and people said if you had two of
them use gay that's what they say my
brother used to draw dickon and with the
icing on my shoe store yeah I was gay
dude if you eat two of those Brigade uh
it's still worth it to me you know still
worth it that's how good they were
do you remember the croissant would get
around your mouth a little bit cuz it
was so enticing it was so flakier stick
to your mouth god I didn't to him like
looks like I'm sucking dick today oh why
wait dude I think we just talked about
food well you're the one that said for
you to turn gay I'm collectible box
Samson first of all a real gentleman who
had to step outside of the house here on
his front porch to admit that he don't
mind a little toaster strudel real man
he went Pop Tart toaster strudels and
you can see a deer right behind him
listen and they got that bucks head
behind a beak tell that deer still alive
it's gone buck bucks in the Frog bucks
I'm toaster strudel all goddamn day
that's my childhood you know what I'm
gonna go but I love them it's too sweet
for me it was too sweet for me I'm gonna
still imma stick with pop-tarts with no
frosting and I'll see y'all in heaven
bro or hell no frosty yeah it was he a
six feet under [ __ ]
59% are with Theo on the pop-tarts
coupler opinion brah that's what it's
called popular
vote Jesus Christ bro you don't know
what things are
[Music]